police is the last this truck near the
russian border in northeastern ukraine
is making a special delivery
badly needed body armor for ukrainian
police and military volunteers capable
of stopping a russian bullet and this
protects
all the important organs yes on a recent
visit to ukraine global news met with a
team responsible for testing body armor
and helmets for the ukrainian military
much of their supply has arrived from
abroad but when they put some of those
armored plates to the test
the results were shocking the bullets
blew through some plates others were
shattered nowadays we have a lot of
imported rest that are penetrated
because of
some companies make
more a lot of money and they
they don't understand what they do
global news traced some of those faulty
plates back to canada it's
heart-wrenching right the blood's on
their hands basically with with this
stuff this ukrainian canadian runs a
toronto tactical equipment shop after
russia invaded ukraine he says demand
for body armor soared and the market was
flooded with fakes
items like this one purchased near
toronto claimed to offer level 4
protection the highest available capable
of stopping an armor-piercing bullet
but when we put this plate to the test
even with a weaker bullet it failed this
bullet went right through
this bullet went right through yeah so
it's through and through so straight
through there
and out the back
another test on a second plate did not
go through but caused major damage this
canadian veteran and former police
officer says users should look for this
stamp very important to have this
information on a plate indicating a
plate is nij certified by the american
national institute of justice
the difference is plain to see after
testing a certified nij level 3 plate
with an even stronger bullet this is
going to ukraine and it's going to be on
the front line it's going to be used
more likely we'll be shot at so i mean
this is life depending there are a lot
of people who are doing war profiteering
back in ukraine global news also saw
faulty tourniquets medical devices that
apply pressure to stop life-threatening
bleeds
this one made in canada using 3d
printing technology failed multiple
tests falling apart
before sufficient pressure was applied
according to dr irina rybinkena who
tests tourniquets for the ukrainian
government thinking that this could save
your life
is a false reassurance
the manufacturer told global news its
products have been used successfully for
years in gaza and it's distributing
tourniquets to ukrainian hospitals
because the need is great like if it's
not perfect but still we have something
i think that is a criminal statement
because what they've got in their hands
would tear
wouldn't halt
wouldn't stop the bleeding
there have been reports of ukrainians
killed after their body armor or
tourniquets failed though none of those
items has been linked to canada
[Applause]
the promise of life-saving equipment can
be deadly if broken
jeff semple global news